hi welcome everyone to stream coco
yeah yes yes oh our neighbors hate us
we're so loud it's great uh oh new
tripod for this camera mouse
yeah oh i love it we got a new tripod
you can't see it but oh it's so pretty
it's beautiful it's so pretty that's
right um welcome everyone stream coco uh
beth moroski's in the chat room with you
jason o'malley creeper in the corner
there we go there's a little bit of
delay today we're playing a game called
gravity rush 2. can you see it there it
says right there gravity rush 2. um
i don't know it looks cool
uh i know nothing about gravity rush one
trailer do you know what's trailer where
like there's like a cat and it's like
this four minute like uh live action
thing where like this girl is doing her
homework about uh einstein and like
gravity and then it like happens to her
like the game happens to her but it's
like
well wait if i can spoil the game bet
people know it look it they look at this
they spoil the entire game this is
abusive yeah this is cr i don't know
they're that we're just gonna abuse some
gravity today to hell with a neighbor
says i see you like bleach
you know bleach is a great way to uh
disinfect your stuff bleach is great um
beth is always more beautiful tim that's
what those are fighting words you don't
like my cheetos shirt come on man
wtf pardon my letters lmao exactly
broadway baby feeling it um oh danny
dwyer says echo gone nice workout mouse
that's the creeper all right we're gonna
play some gravity rush i know nothing
about this game
but i do know one thing you always start
at the beginning new game
yeah we haven't played this game before
so
eat
a fat one here we go
oh i love cell animation
[Music]
god the air quality looks terrible this
is like los angeles on a normal day
yeah
me driving to work in the morning yeah
exactly it's terrible asteroid you suck
thank you hakeem appreciate that happy
monday hey what up rhys good to see you
so crazy rainbows you're so glad they
kept all the costume options
uh
what is the deal with this game who
knows about this game explain it to me
because i was reading on the back and
just like manipulate gravity and soar
the skies in an open world
okay
that's all we're gonna do is just
manipulate gravity yep
are we going down to a black hole or
something
uh oh tory angel i think is 21 since
yesterday happy birthday tori angel
have greetings from india whoa hey there
thank you hey daxter what's up
this is real life johnny king unless you
played the vive in which case you're
still stuck in the vive get out
sup bray pal what's going on you don't
suck you're more or less tolerable hey
thanks oh and this thing is speaking to
me ooh
can you hear that yeah that's cool that
was the noise it was making i like that
all right
uh check your surroundings
so far it looks like i am in a
bloodstream oh my god am i in somebody's
body
whoa dog
yeah i don't
know
jones
oh good reference
i can't jump i can't uh i can't do
anything
i look you know i look this i kind of
look like a weird big daddy
great way to start a game on a on a
platform moving extremely slowly
it's anticipation hey what's up
this game is trippy moses is your shirt
spicy chicken tenders no
regular it's crunchy
cheetos it's just guys
it kind of does look like chicken it's
not flaming hot it's not flaming hot
cheetos it's crunchy cheetos classic
thank you
also if you like puffs you're dead to me
so if you like puffs and you're in the
chat please just stop watching you're
dead to me should i leave i don't count
you as a pup
don't do it don't kill again don't kill
again what are the other puffs that
aren't cheetahs what's like
i don't care puffs are dead to me i
don't care if you like puffs don't watch
the stream i'm telling you right now
you're dead to me i hate you what i just
like things that are so hot oh my god
we're still going down oh so you like me
is that why you like me
all right here we are oh there's a bunch
of other miners
and they're like mining a big egg that's
a this looks like a good idea what is
happening
this looks like ruins
i'm into the design of this game by the
way rendezvoused with 101.
it's a bunch of big daddies yeah this is
creepy fun to life
why am i not just talking about clueless
gamer we cut all of me out so conan can
be funnier
you know uh first rule first law of
power never outshine the master guys
i've been reading this book called the
48 laws of power
they read a lot in prisons i'm learning
uh show business is a lot like prison
first rule never outshine the master
it's true never reach on the master
that's why path never outshines me yep
slash outshines me all the time
you spend your entire day out shining me
oh bottom live i love the shirt
generally just like most cheetos but
crunchy's the superior foreign cheetos
thank you bowden live points to you
points to you
all right we're walking i have no idea
where we are
wow this looks a lot like when i drink
too much whiskey
and then throw up on the wall
yo from france yo balkas yo right back
at you
sup dude what's up youtube guy
shouldn't cone in the entire show be
airing in the uk these kind of segments
seem nice the username is a dare for
those who wondering who
darth vader um
yeah i mean i don't know that's not my
deal
the sweet taste of puffs come on dude
puffs are puffs are like the cotton
candy of cheetos it's just un you just
they're unfulfilling where are we going
by the way
welcome to stream coco where we're going
to be walking in giant undersea suits
for 90 minutes
good i tell you you're wrong
you're wrong i can't even say your name
and you're wrong
this game is creepy like jordan
schlansky but we haven't murdered
anything yet so it's not exactly like
jordan slansky
has great insta story yeah
that's true
don't encourage jordan on instagram are
those new blinds room looks great i
think you might you know what have you
seen that video instagram husbands have
you seen video instagram husbands it's
basically like uh
hot girls and then it's it's from the
point of view of the guy who has to
shoot the hot girl doing stuff
you know what i'm saying like oh like
she's like oh and then you it pulls back
you just see the guy like recording it
for her or whatever uh it's great um
you know what i'm saying like i just
don't encourage jordan i think he makes
other people shoot stuff for him oh look
at these eggs we're gonna
get in there this is
vaguely sexual
in a crazy way it's about reproduction i
feel like this is a terrible that's
can't be good
this giant
watch out what are we supposed to what
do you mean watch out oh my god
i'm getting hazard pay for this oh no
how long are these credits for oh my god
forever i think they're over now
uh read by nature
then you're doing us right i appreciate
it
look at those egg pokers says nico
you're right we have a message from
someone named travis whoa shirt is too
loud
is cool
travis
i'm coming for you travis
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait why
are we taking off all of our clothes ah
why are we wearing a tank
why why are we wearing these giant
things if we could just take them off i
don't get it
why is there a giant
what is happening
oh i see we are going to die then
why are we leaving this oh so we can
maybe run faster
yeah it's
holding us down
damn
i love this animation style by the way
this looks so cool
oh god
so far gravity is this is not a oh god
where do we go this way
i like that's the way i jump too by the
way like
that's so that's so not the way to jump
you can't tell me you're just oh jeez oh
boy
digging the cell shading yeah it's cool
celsius is awesome
uh where do we go right here dude
this way bro
you
you know what this kind of looks scary
but i bet this is one of those times
where you actually can't die because
it's like too early in the game
they don't want you to quit you know
kind of a tutorial still or something
yeah it's still kind of like
god she jumps like an idiot
oh boy oh whoops
worn out smart guy by the way why did we
take off our shoes that was dumb oh
we're dead
god that guy's so hot these people oh
here we go
it's carmen san diego
she's come to save us oh she's got a
that's a weird birthmark
red red dead redemption 2. can't wait
what's up jonathan
ooh
wait what's happening
this is cool
two lost grab suits our rules demand we
always pay our debts sorry doesn't cover
our
losses oh she's hungry
stomach problems
oh she's hungry
oh she's like the slave master
[Music]
what are they mining
[Music]
it's gravity cool
i wish comic sa comixology like did this
when you got comic books
is that a course for banga
how do we end up like this oh we're so
hungry i love like we just survived a
crazy thing and we're already like i
want a snack yeah
she's pregnant with an alien stephen i
don't think that's true i showed started
with incident new har real line can i
see something by the way just very
quickly
look fantasy people who write fantasy
stuff you don't have to make every name
insane okay
people can still have normal names like
new holler a lot i don't need that
it's dumb it makes it's like i hate that
name i hate this game we pulled in a
perfect gravity storm and drifted
through the rift planes all right
it could just be like cleveland too you
know what i'm saying like in japanese oh
is it
is this a truly japanese game or is this
like
well in that case i guess it's fine
if it's a translated name then we're
okay with it but if it's like just name
it like detroit you know what i'm saying
like why can't everything just be in
america yeah why can't it all be
american um i'm a terrible person here
we go when we welcome we were with the
boat people who work the city stolen by
this storm for ore their leader lisa
triola slaves okay
everyone is trying to be game of thrones
yeah
game of thrones it's like everything is
every it's like ridiculous yeah it makes
me it's like enough
like people can just be called gary you
know although like gary queen of the
dragons doesn't really
you know what i'm saying then the same
ring to it it does have the same ring
gary
uh let's see like what's that guy's name
the throthgar the dude poured the gold
on the other guy's head
dothraki something other it's i don't
need it
i have no imagination you're right i do
suck that's true anthony all right the
days when i uh uh hex with gravity queen
ooh she used to be gravity queen
oh man where's raven at the language is
supposed to be an odd mix of french and
japanese oh okay interesting i'm into
that
[Music]
thanks it was like this in the first
game too crazy rainbows thank you you
know what i like it i take it back what
is my name blair that's a mess yeah
maybe i'm just angry because i've been
cursed with a terrible belgian name that
sounds like i'm dry heating
like blurred
blur like that's my last name oh they're
all saying call drogo though
yeah actually that's a pretty cool name
i take it back you know what
let's get silly with the names who cares
right
marosky yeah what is that garbage yeah
morosky that's better cleveland's such a
boring name sorry cleveland
cal drago yeah
82-13 i don't think you should be
working don't work
never work
yeah where's ducks look at them ducks
yeah also or as they're probably called
in this uh in this mode like
far swingies look at those farchwingies
over there
you know they're probably not ducks
because that's too boring of a name
right
chapter one here we go
yeah blart sucks you're right
yep a lot of blair hate thanks anthony
anthony you don't need to keep saying i
suck once is fine yeah i saw it
uh here we go something up
first swingies there we go ducks
rv dab
uh please do not sprint gravitational
power so basically we're in a world
where gravity is harvested or something
right
oh they're still hungry
you know what i'm going to go on record
lisa's tattoo is stupid looking i hate
that tattoo
sure means something to it also don't
get tattooed so close to your eye what
are you doing yeah that's that needle
oh my god lisa's a [ __ ]
look after the light you tell her to
look after the livestock yeah she's
rough with her people
ugh i hate her
you know what beige is a dumb color and
it looks bad on you lisa i just want to
point that out this is cool look at this
dude this game is gorgeous oh my god
i love this
hmm
hey you got something on that
lazy work as a hungry worker we got it
all right jeez you won't get fed
this that's the same way they treat us
here
you don't work you know that's like
conan lacey worker is a hungry worker
yeah they don't feed us don't
that's not true beth what did you when
you were an intern what did you eat and
be honest
i was very cheap i don't know cheap i
was thrifty i used to just order
frugally responsible i'd say rice
and beans
epiketer moss and it comes with free
chips yeah entire meal three dollars too
many carbs maybe three bucks i was in my
early twenties three bucks now i'm in my
mid-twenties it's different that's right
it's so different the bodies
all right
no no puffy cheetos are bad lexington
come on feed her puppy cheetah uh is
there supposed to be a green tint on the
game ah
it does look it feels a little greenish
i guess
i guess we could go in and i don't know
figure it out system what do i want here
um
photo mode look at these people dancing
around
uh i don't know what's happening here
guess what returning the game it looks
pretty intentional
yeah you know what creeper says it looks
intentional so it's intentional
let's see here where do we go yeah why
is she running in wedges chewbacca's
dead
not great that's true i'm not into her
um
i'm not in there the way she jumps i
hate that
that's a deal breaker if we were dating
if we were on a date and she jumped like
that i feel like i have to go
i'm sorry i have to leave
who jumps like this i'm just saying
right
okay uh over the mining boat it's
obsessed with mining awesome
the girl had red eyes
i don't know if i had red eyes do you
think i'd be more attractive or less
attractive you'd be more uh
facially interesting
and maybe that would attract well it's
so romantic
i love when beth tries to sweet talk me
you're facially interesting you're fit
yeah
you're facially curious
yep
all right where are we going here
yeah where's that mining boat oh here we
go
you know what i always appreciate a game
that tells me where to go because i
always get lost
so i appreciate the help
here we
are oh that's messiah right there
ooh if you had red eyes look like a
mouse good point
yeah you're right i would look like a
mouse maybe she's part mouse
now
tall tales
dude i was a gravity queen
back off bro
yeah don't be mean to cat
there's a lot of drama
i don't need this gossip
oh
there's a lot of talking it you know i
thought it was going to be a lot of
flying around and kicking yeah there's a
lot of talking in this game not that i
don't like it
i'm just saying there's a lot of talking
yeah you know what i feel you there cat
oh god
i'm doing a good job bro
you know people need to deliver your own
yeah deliver your own message
you're just tinkering
i gotta go back to the windmill thing
geez oh pete
you know i used to be gravity queen i
don't need to deal with this
[ __ ]
and i jump like an idiot what kind of
queen jumps like that what do you think
i can make this jump i'm doing it
nope
i'm dead oh i'm dead
she looks cool though when she's falling
to her death
all right you approve of that
where are we going here
so i try to make that jump again i think
i should
i mean this game is awesome looking i'll
say that i would definitely watch this
as a movie
where did you get your shirt someone is
asking i got it on the internet i don't
remember where look on the internet
oh
oh now i'm on this pipe oh i fell down
again it died
first death second death
truthfully i've been working out i've
been eating a lot of cheetos thanks
truth lee
oh you know what i also like when games
feel bad for me and just put me next to
the objective
at least not maintaining my cheeriness
this game is all about just like one
dude it's a lot of like interpersonal
issues
maybe it's like an hr exercise
search google for cheetos shirt
i am stupid that's true
a lot of a lot of blade heat today on
the chat
but you know what i deserve it bring it
on i say it was that kind of a weekend
got you drunk missed my friend's
birthday
yeah
he didn't really care though oh i just
died again oh but i did a cannonball
have i ever had sake i have never had
sake i bet saki have had a lot of
sucking he
oh it does
but in a good way don't follow your
death please
all right here we go here we go here we
go
uh
you know they couldn't have built like a
few more bridges like god son of a
just can't everything be connected not
that we don't like you but conan is
pretty much queen yeah i know conan is
pointing no it's fine and you don't like
me i've seen these comments
is anthony gonna say i suck again or did
he leave already oh jonathan rodriguez
said you suck thanks jonathan i knew i
know i could count on somebody to make
me feel me feel bad
i like it when it goes to this though
i'm a big fan of comic books this is
cool this is a cool effect this is cool
oh lisa you are
straightening my doll's clothes
there we go coming in hot
distractor
[Music]
oh you're with the floofy wiggles or
whatever i said the ducks
why is there why am i sleeping in a duck
[ __ ] yeah
i was the queen of gravity
wait
i thought you were already in chapter
one i thought this is aggressive
this this duck is
this duck is aggressive look at that
look at this duck
it's just like
i like the dallas oh
that is an aggressive duck
oh my god
duck hentai exactly
and i thought we were already chapter
one it's like what is this episode one
of chapter one
there's many parts oh my god there's so
much reading in this game prejudice
there's like a new chapter every 10
pages am i right
up top no i'm not high-fiving that i'm
sick anyway don't touch me oh yeah
oh my god
it's all complicated everyone is
everybody's daughter
that duck is how i feel watching yeah
that's how i feel playing this
oh my god can we please just kick
something or fly around
the ducks are spies for lisa oh god yeah
right exactly her little birds
now we gotta go find cece
and i'm running in wedges come on
gravity
rush to
there's lisa
[Music]
she'll be back i threw her off the ledge
the duck is the final boss
that's a good one
well you know what the internal question
is would you rather fight a horse sized
duck or a hundred duck sized horses
i hate this question i know it's an
internal question i'm just saying
i don't know if there's a right answer
i saw in reddit somebody's making a game
where you just like beat up toddlers
where like a hundred toddlers are trying
to kill you you just like keep kicking
them and stuff i think they're even with
toddlers
um
she's that she's just chilling
everyone's so relaxed here
for being like floating up in the air on
a crazy planet
find dusty duck-sized horses i guess old
salty sack hates this game all right
it's not like there are many places to
go here
uh okay
i don't
have in california doesn't have duck
sauce i wonder that all the time what's
duck sauce and why do we care it's like
sweet sauce that comes with like chinese
food oh i think it's like an east
northern east coast thing scanning
pancakes also missing in this town oh
scott i do love against guy picking hey
here all the ducks
what up ducks ducks and ducks and ducks
my duck crew
who with me who whipped me ducks
who whipped me
just rolling around with some ducks
that's me rolling around with ducks okay
i gotta get it have you heard him don't
kill the baby
don't kill them don't kill the baby yeah
that's a great that's where you're like
a parent trying to fight your baby
you're like the baby's trying to like
run around and like has a laser pointer
it shines in your eyes and you're like
it's great
oh yeah
thank you for the jacket compliment i
got it for christmas
uh sorry i don't know alex i think her
power-up is to run in a straight line i
don't know where i'm supposed to be
going
did you play the original people
i didn't play the original no but i wish
i did because i'm guessing in that game
she was a queen and could like [ __ ] [ __ ]
up
and this one she's a
woman who runs around in shorts and
wedges sorry from the bottom starting
from the bottom now we're still at the
bottom
you know what i don't appreciate this
game making fun of me
i got the chat crapping on me i got this
game crapping on me i can't find stupid
cece
at least i probably threw her off the
stupid ledge
it's a big old floating rock and no one
say anything about it
do you think their
bathroom just goes off into the void
well like how does the bathroom work on
like a cruise ship
do they just dump it i always remember
this no it goes into a tank that's
disgusting
and then they dump the whole tank and
they done the whole thing
i think it's a giant don't you think
does anybody out there work on a cruise
ship i think it's where does the boobs
go i think the poop's going in like a
septic tank
but that's a lot of poops then they're
you're carting so many think about i
mean you're right look i don't know
it's gross anyway you slice it and
especially if you slice it it's gross
i don't want to be alive anymore yep
well you and me both
all i want to do is find cece here
i am a cruise ship you are a cruise ship
yeah i am a cruise ship in the chat
cruise ship is me
it me cruise ship
hit me
any hype in the first game in the first
game she was a homeless person that
lived in the sewer and had gravity
powers well at least she had gravity
powers
oh man this game hey there's a pig
you know i could use one of them arrows
they just saved and dumped out
get it at fort at port there we go but
the port
oh wait a second there's another person
to talk to i think it was like a waste
management thing
as a cruise ship i do dump into mother
ocean
it me i like cruise ship mitchell cece
bird coop i was just in the birdcage
i like it too cruise ship you're my
favorite person to chat today also
because you're the only person who
hasn't said i suck so you're on my
you're in my good graces
i'm not telling lisa
the gravel pit
got it gravel pit
oh right
we should go to canada with norman
mcdonald oh she's right there that's a
good idea yeah that's a good idea
just not even for the show just us
personally
i did a great podcast of door mcdonald
oh yeah uh yeah and we talked about
tolstoy he reads toaster every morning
he's so smart he's super smart really
great guy
lulafon i didn't say uh says i didn't
say you suck not yet
it's not over yet chad's not over
oh bonjour maui bap
truthfully i will find you all right
find a way truthfully
so basically let me get this right the
storm in the beginning
sucked us into a wormhole and we ended
up on this like [ __ ] popsicle right i
guess so but like lisa came together
oh my god
dusty i don't know
some people are like lol imagine conan
playing this yeah
yeah exactly
that's pushing dragon ball oh touch of
red i love dragon ball i was super into
dragon ball for a while
oh thanks ragram said my tumblr's very
inspiring thank you
answer folks questions on there if you
got questions
look at this
now we're doing a little now things are
getting interesting
now we got ourselves a card game all
right
yep it's a long way down because you've
been down there a couple times and now
you're going down there again i'm so
sorry oh brother
do you think she falls forever
forever yeah i know exactly i feel you i
forgot that person's name but all the
poop going on to the farm animals i feel
you on that one all right here we go
this girl's hot by the way
did it
here we go
greetings from germany hey germany hey
germs sorry mini
blade was just there
i was there see i call it germany i
think that's how it's supposed to be
pronounced not just germany it's germany
thank you it's a hard g like a gif
also if you say jiff
like
you're dead to me also if you like
cheetahs puffs or you say jiff we're not
from yeah jeff is and we'll never be
friends
now i've finally said something that
beth agrees with wholeheartedly
oh no
oh no
levy
yep let's try let's try worm eye things
yup look at me evading
dead dead immediately how many times
have i died this is crazy
all i have to do is just not fall off
we're like just hanging out this is why
i don't go hiking because i just
immediately like this is me in real life
first of all i wear wedges when i hike
which is stupid
but i fall off things easily guys i'm
dumb i'm very top heavy my head is very
large
dead
nope we're alive here we go
now things are fourth death
who greetings from kenya mike mikey
they're jellyfish things is that the
credit correct uh
whoa
uh oh
well well well lisa looks like the
shoe's on the other foot now
well carmen san diego's so upset
google carbon san diego and put it in
the chat for those people do you guys
know carmen san diego she looks exactly
carmen san diego
yeah kevin i should have played this
game wearing wedges instead i'm wearing
boots like an idiot
the wedges saved me i agree lulathon
i need to get cece back just leave cece
to die nobody cares about cece what has
cece ever done for us when she signed
her yearbook she was like just signed it
she didn't even write anything nice in
it
i do suck thank you
it's the aaron sucks stream everyone
man everyone's got b up their ass what's
going on
you know what i don't i don't suck i'm
sorry guys i don't suck you're wrong i
don't suck
i'm a nice guy i'm a good dude
he's a good dude
i don't ghost people go people ghost me
i have ghosts a few people but in my
life but you know look we've all done
things we're not proud of
[Music]
damn it
oh
it's the worst
this game is like
oh god anthony lemus back with him you
suck oh he's back
thanks anthony appreciate it
all right let's see here i appreciate
you bro
i appreciate you
ah here we go a phrase i've started
saying a lot which i'm trying to not say
is i'm here for it oh yeah i'm here for
it
oh
it's your boy
duck shack
here he
ah is shack
but what happened to the ducks that
can't be good
it's all about
whoa
hey it's a cat it's a space cat what yes
dusty dusty the space cat oh man this
game's getting good dude
dusty my girl
[Music]
grab the giant navi's attention r1
i hit r1
what just happened
what is this
i don't know
oh yes
why couldn't i do this before
i fell off so many times
and this fingers
oh i got killed
all right we're back
you can see all my veins and stuff what
is happening why is there a giant snake
hand
throwing rocks oh i got killed every
time i have to do something i get killed
i've died nine times
dude why was i running around
this is great
wow i went into the hand
time to finish it
finishers
whoa
dope damn
sounds coming out
dude this is great
[Music]
i get like all
like i have a rash all over my oh my god
wow
[Music]
oh you're welcome by the way
my god oh so dusty the space cat is the
source of our powers yeah that must be
it
oh dude wait a second i'm gonna i gotta
put the hurting on lisa
oh dude
please can we just like do the the vane
thing on lisa
please let's do the vayne thing
no
oh great no more no more duck shack for
me
i'm so excited no more duck shack
sid how did sid get hurt
dude come on man we have gravity powers
so wait let me just get this straight i
saved the whole settlement
i got a space cat i have gravity powers
my boy duck shack slash sid is hurt
and it's bad i do double duty
what do you think a space cat eats
um
like stars
stars
space cat food
oh dude look at me
looking good
yeah dusty
i love it space cats still can't speak
anything but cat
[Music]
she still hasn't anything anything to
eat true yeah
oh yeah here we go oh this is great
oh here we go
all right things are really picking up
now watch they're just gonna be like
take a message over to barry
tell john he's gonna be late for dinner
this is so cool
whoa this is awesome all right
oh now i could really get around and
tell people
messages
uh
while floating oh wow oh okay oh this
aims it oh this i'm gonna be bad at this
already
this is cool
floating
i died i died i died somehow
i'm finding new ways to die hey barbara
what's up
welcome to motion sickness
correct yep sorry guys apologies
[Music]
got it all right
okay
when you float around people it messes
with their gravity too
dope
got it
okay
where's cece over there
oh cool
oh yeah let's talk to cece now we have
gravity powers this
aim of the billions free form no need to
go direct to the dot got it
how you pipe height
totally just kill those people system
mrs man face
oh man they're really going in there
how do i lose all the weight uh
eat less that's what it is man
you don't don't eat crap
it's all diet
um and then you get muscles from
exercise that's the deal
oh my god you don't care about this
dusty's cool though
let's go fight something
i get it
i think i just killed some people
who's talking to me
dude i would do this all day
this is cool i gotta say who's calling
me
wouldn't that be cold yeah what does
this girl ever wear pants
i can do it with this thing too
hey it's you dog
can i
yeah i'm doing it dude i'm tilting the
yup i'm doing it all
so i can't just go anywhere i want
something has to appear
oh thank you helpful thing
i'm really nailing this gravity thing
guys
more talking our favorite yep i'm myself
don't push too hard oh i still got to do
mining
no i don't can i make money off this
windmill boat
where's the windmill boat
i mean it's pretty easy i gotta say to
float around it's kind of fun here
[Music]
okay
wonder what he'll say when he sees me
now probably damn
[Music]
nice weird snake leggings
this guy's going to be a dick i can't
even see it how's it hanging look at him
he's got sneering
you suck
oh my god nice necklace you idiot
where'd you get that hot topic
[Music]
dude i can control gravity why aren't
you amazed
what the
oh god what a bummer
you suck
practice but there are no people yeah
cause everyone's a jerk
i was a jerk in this game
oh angry reacts only i'm just saying
it's stupid
i'm out of here later suckers
we're going to fly over to that boat i'm
going to float over this way
this is probably what flying would
really be like because how can you like
orient yourself in the air you know yeah
now i guess i shouldn't fall off anymore
but i see where am i going
oops ouch
uh
am i going here this way
oh man i'm bad at this all right
does this make me like more hungry am i
expect how many calories am i spending
like doing this you know oh yeah i
wonder
is this like a good workout
[Music]
you can pretty much go where you want
aim that way hit the button then when
you want to change hit the button and
quickly pick where you want to go next
yeah find a life i just want to float
around too
stratford bob
oh gravity cat is propelling you oh wait
the cat is the source of my powers yeah
the cat is the answer to everything got
it
okay cool
just like in real life the cats are the
answer to everything
i mean i'm close enough right
oh god whoops
oh boy oh geez
i turned into a big ball of nothing
super game sniper you're right
whatever
this is eureka
do not tease me about the puffs you know
i hate puffs
i hate puffs oh god what's the point
plus like they're just all air you know
what i'm saying so when you get like if
you take a bag of puffs you take a bag
of crunchy cheetos you're getting so
much more for your money if they're
crunchy that's true they're so more
solid density in terms of yeah in terms
of cheeto density which is important
oh whoops
wait aren't i here
[Music]
man my eyes i look so cool like this i
have a bunch of sea urchins in my face
and my legs
[Music]
i'm killing this gravity thing man my
cat is dope where do you get it gravity
cat
uh hdna i have felt sick uh playing a
game
not this one but sometimes oh
sometimes when i play um when i twitch
myself my screen is right in front of my
face and if i play on that screen it's
just right here it makes me sick
i was playing this game layers of fear
where you're a painter who's killed his
whole family spoiler alert
and painted with their blood and um it
kind of made me sick
on twitch thanks twitch thanks twitch
you guys are the best
oh that sucked
i have a starfish for the face yeah
aim for the bridge
uh grinching yes we're shooting a
clueless gamer exclusive camera's gonna
be shot i think in two weeks very
excited
be fun we just had a meeting about it
today it's very exciting
boom
gravity gauge oh see i knew they were
going to pull something where you can't
just float around
uh all right
okay
got the energy gems aptly named
if you're super going to fall into a
wall you can uh
okay
got it all right
oh i see so now like this is my whoops
whoops whoops
damn it
yeah that's a good idea grab bad
let's turn off the motion controls i
think it's making slash everyone sick
how do i turn off the motion controls
the next question
what are statistics
ooh
two percent two percent damn's right
[Music]
i don't know how to turn off the thing
um motion controls
oh well
here we go
we did not play first grab rush no was
it good
do people like gravity rush one
or as i call it gravity rush
she still jumps like an idiot i'm just
gonna say it
oh boy we're too high
too high captain
oh yeah look at my gravity powers are
running out
i wonder if i can of course i can
it was amazing wow hey 918 porsche happy
birthday
message retracted okay
astounding astounding eh
i'm not gravity so high so they're
supposed to be high uh high expectations
for gravity rush too so far there's a
lot of talking
you're right granddad it's way better
when you
when you just use the sticks it's a
thousand times better
[Music]
eureka's getting a headache from the
game i mean i'm not very good at it so
best game of the veto wow
awesome
did it have the same
this stuff on the video
i'm just not going to use the motion
controls
oops
what time is it here it is
12 52 in the afternoon
it's lunchtime
i'm off my game yeah oh [ __ ]
[Music]
what am i doing uh harry salt right now
uh no we're good
the music is super soothing i agree i'm
like napping
controls are a little nicer philip rinky
says
like some jams
don't mind if i do
oh geez she goes fast oh my god
i threw up on watching this thing to
help me lose weight you're welcome
i died
i'm changing the camera controls kids
i wouldn't be off my gear if i went to
camera settings all right fine
challenge accepted
[Music]
uh
oh you know yeah
oh motion sensation oh camera zero right
boom turn it off
is that better is everyone feeling less
sick i mean you still have to look at my
face so you're going to be kind of sick
guys
um can i get a you suck from the stream
anybody
anybody want to hit me up with you suck
yeah i'm not doing the motion sensor bro
i'm a lady genji
i'm a lady
yeah there we go thanks guys
ah that's right bring it up
give it to me give it to me all of it i
want all of it
i had a dream that aaron sucked in that
dream and i woke up and he was streaming
and he still sucks yes who was that
that was elaborate thank you
thank you
oh yeah close my mouth wow that's a new
one nice guys
i feel the i feel the uh non-love
where am i going here anybody know
i suck at most things miss man face
video games most of all
and i got all these cool powers what
should i do where am i supposed to be
going let's go see our ducks ubers
what up ducks watch this something
called yeah i got some ducks with me
yeah the dub the ducks this is what i
wanted
let's go ducks
are the ducks with me
other ducks didn't come with me
yeah oh
dude this is great i love the ducks oh
this is a party right now
oh i'm loving this
i wish i could do this in real life it'd
be so fun with ducks
just look all these ducks just
they're not making any noise
this is how you do it guys this is how
you live this is us living
welcome to the work week
welcome to the work week y'all
oh jeez huh
we heard the ducks i don't know what
happened
i'm going to kill some ducks
can we bring them with us for the rest
of the game
10 out of 10 ign's to strive for bob
sorry
all right don't give me that look hey
right back at you there buddy he's not
ducks
is that true yes
what are the terms of my employment uh
they ended a year ago
i just sneak in here and uh play games
on mondays that's all i do now
um
so uh anyone know what we're supposed to
be doing uh here what's our next one
sometimes the game gets peter says [ __ ]
off you animal
it's true
sorry peter hope you're not watching
are they geese or ducks i guess they're
geese
i don't know what's the difference
between a goose and a duck
they're different like different birds
i don't know i don't go to school i was
self-taught
yep
it's a gauss there we go
how about oh star barf
asked how long have i worked for conor
i've come in since one do we do other
things besides closed gamer yes what
those things are vary from day to day
and week to week but yes
mostly crying
a lot of weeping sometimes there's some
gas
depending on what i've eaten
um
[Music]
so
toadskis they have like huge necks oh
next
uh like ducks and swans had sex
what what that say you don't know things
you can't do that
okay lonely request
i'll find sid is what i'm supposed to be
doing
oh my god this game is so much about
finding people and doing things i can't
stand it
you know what though i guess a lot of
games to weave a large tapestry you have
to start small
so true
look at my hair so cool looking
this game is fun i will say when you
stop talking to people when you actually
go and do [ __ ] oh yeah you're like well
i'm gonna leave now
everyone must hate me because every time
i turn on the gravity they all fall down
hey you all seen sid anywhere anyone
where would sid be
who's the lady with a mac
who is the lady with the mac who's that
lady
i don't even know who knows
you know let's go down here and see some
pigs
pigs
uh let's make the pig float
floating pigs
what up pigs
they're like please
that pig's like police love a god a
little pig butt
he's floating there
we have fun don't we pigs
jesus hey i'm planning to watch some old
sims episodes
which ones would you recommend monorail
monorail number one
what else connor once told me um
monorail joke
at the end if you've never seen monorail
there's one final joke that he didn't
feel like he
he loved it he had it ended kind of
differently
and then then someone else in the room
had a funnier joke and so it ended that
way but he had a different ending which
was interesting he told me one time i
actually told my friend who was visiting
the office my friend was like i love
monreal and then conan kind of busted
out with a little monorail
trivia
he also did
new kid on the block
homer goes to
let me go to college
i'm not sure where i'm supposed to be
going
i'm getting good at my gravity powers
though
are we using obs or xsplit what are we
using explicit
obs is no good
i'm not a fan of obs
i love xsplit we love xsplit o'malley
says
loudly
xsplit for president you've been helpful
xsplit for praise
well i've looked all over this stupid
floating city and i can't find anybody
so where are we shifts your gravity
where it says you can shift gravity to
the side of the building oh that's cool
oh grow dad thank you that helps a lot
was i a big fan of conan when i first
applied for a position on the show i
watched conan i was a fan
um not like a super fan but i watched
him and um
it was weird i remember like after i
started working on the show actually on
facebook somebody put up a photo of me
in my dorm room
with my roommates and
we were watching conan was on the tv and
it's weird to think about the fact that
like a year after that photo was taken i
was working in that studio it was very
odd but yeah i was a fan
i do suck matt maniac
um and one thing that blew me away
that i didn't understand when i started
working here
was like a lot of the people who are on
the show are just writers on our show so
i remember seeing like oh it's a guy
with bulletproof legs it was brian
mccann
uh and brian stack who's the guy who
shoots him and is like it's really mean
in that sketch but is like the nicest
dude ever so i was like oh why are all
these like
like actors walking around i didn't
understand how um incestuous it was
uh
because this was recorded during
halloween because i secretly shirt
oh cheetos
no we live we live yo
that's right
my name is charlie fair enough
you're bloody good at this game that's
not true
oh i see you're being sarcastic yeah i
can't find sid man
anyways any tips or sid is anyone anyone
where's it at
you could use one of those arrows
just aim at the sky and fly up a bit to
see if you can look down and find the
destination
all right
that's from grabad they've been helping
yep
take your shirt off to prove your life
yeah
no nobody take your clothes off nope you
get to see a shoulder though there you
go damn check out this knee yeah look at
that knee she's got going on
by the way us answering your question
idiot you saw me come on where's sid
zero i know no one knows where he is
sid might be lost in schlansky's office
good one yeah exactly
can i get on that thing
oh i can kick
look at me not falling off now guys
aren't you all proud of me
um
i hate this
level i hate sid
i hate uh a lot of things right now
i'm looking for sid bro
i wear special ghosts i eat cheetos very
smart
find that carmen san diego lady i don't
know where she is either
am i being an idiot i feel like i've
been looking around i'm not i'm actually
looking while i'm talking you guys
you see it on the big rock
do we go back to the big rock
is it like over there
oh better look around banger
i've been looking around banger dude
i love people just fall down when i show
up
where is sid dudes
oh this is so annoying i hate this
god damn
let me suck your knee i know bang a
millions i'm trying to find sid
well he was hurt right so i'm looking
for the hospital
whatever passes from one around here
can't talk to these people
do you think he's over there in that
little shack
maybe right
[Music]
i got some dope kicks though now
oh my god ah space cat ate a bunch of
rats that was dope
magical cat i love that uh this person
hello you apparently there's more one
person with gravity
let's fight
all right sid's not over there
i feel like i've looked around this area
quite a bit
can i kick somebody
well that one's running for me
all right no sid no sid
is there a map for us to check
[Music]
this map is insane by the way that's
crazy
so we know he's not over here
i mean we'll just keep looking all right
so
down here
dude he is at banga
give the controller to the check over
here on that do you want to play no
there you go
you'll have to teach me how to use a
controller
i'm bad it's said to look around venga
that's what i'm doing oh there's sid we
found him where
said sid
you trickster
uh since being oh he's hitting with he's
hitting on some ladies he's got a
robotic arm
sid was just hitting on girls oh sid
that's so sick of you
that's so sad
this is about to have a foursome it
looks like
oh here i come here i come to [ __ ] block
sid
get ready
oh my god oh my god i can't stand this
just is there some
i trim the chest for you
[Music]
sid is kind of a layabout you know yeah
he's kind of a um
he's kind of given to giving people a
rudy dude yeah you know
ow ow
why isn't lisa up his ass you know
classic sid
we hate sid
oh oh
that's it
to your stations why am i gonna fight
for you you're a terrible person
episode two here we go
yeah [ __ ]
oh i'm gonna show you what i can do all
right
why am i still mining i'm a gravity
queen
why am i still mining and listening to
this terrible person
it doesn't make any sense can i kick her
jeez
ah she's impervious to my kicks
oh i hit in this freaking a-hole
oh my god i'm this guy i want to kill
this guy
yeah i remember dragging the rest of us
down yeah i'm gonna drag you down idiot
no liver twitch tv no free food there is
sometimes i got these oh we're going
down into the heart of the jelly oh yeah
look at these almonds there are dollars
taste right that's right sometimes you
get almonds
uh i think this is a i think this is a
ps4 exclusive we're playing gravity rush
2 today
and so far things are just starting to
get exciting we've got some gravity
powers provided by our space cat
whose name is dusty of course
uh and uh we are a former gravity queen
who's
forced to work in the gravity mines for
a woman named lisa who looks just like
the woman from uh carmen san diego
yeah the guy does all right here we are
god this is miserable work
yeah i don't know half-lifer
dude this guy needs to just
go get caught in a fire
oh you're the mining king buy a better
necklace
oh i hate this guy
oh detailed tutorial
[Music]
oh god i just get to kick him open he's
got to use a big drill
it's gonna be so easy
all right let's go
i'll take that thank you
nope i'm gonna work right here thanks a
lot
take that messiah
but now [ __ ] i got all the [ __ ] gems
where's he at i want to take everything
he's trying to mine where's he at
oh can't find anything huh
yeah dog
can i kick this tree open
nope nope no kick in the trees
dude i'm just killing it right now
killing the game
ah
this game does make you crazy in your
head by the way i'm upside down
where am i going
up here i think
your face dick
that's right eat it someone wants to
know how many frescas you had today zero
zero but i'm about to have like six
too many
i'm gonna mine some difficult rock y'all
can just take it take the day off
because your girl gots it
look at these moves oh
see how happy i am to be doing something
in this game
or an hour in and i finally get to do
something it's so exciting
i got this fellas boom
you guys yelling at me
it's gonna be a long day what are you
talking about
i just did like all of your work
guys are pricks everyone here in this
game is a [ __ ]
yeah mine is no sweat
yeah messiah is not impressed
oh okay cool hey there's somebody cool
hey thanks pal
get deeper into the mining site so i
shall
it's not mine
well okay fair enough
where and why i don't understand what
this is like did people live here at one
time
ah
sorry
i will say this game is getting good the
gravity powers in this game are very fun
when you actually are not looking for
sid
you know
you're not just running around the whole
time
the controls are pretty great
yeah this is trump 2019
uh
down
this is great man i got arrows pointing
the way i'm supposed to go
this is dope
oops
ah
all right so there's a dope i can't
remember
which way is up
that's kind of a problem this game
does kind of blow your mind a bit
oh yeah
what is the plane yeah
[Music]
all right
so i'm just kicking open giant uh i
don't know grinch this is a 60 game
yeah this is see it's fun now right
exactly thanks hero thanks for joining
us
and now i kind of got the hang of this
it's great
i will say like in the defense of the
people make gravity rush too
it is kind of a complicated concept
like to change gravity around like so
nuts is is kind of um
so i can understand why like the
tutorial has to be kind of long
because now that i got the hang of it
it's super fun
scarabs
[Music]
uh she's just flying toward us just
crotch first what if someone what if she
hit something
[Music]
it's dangerous this game is fun jake
watson
bethan does it
yeah
oh i know how to kick there's one thing
i know how to do
well i just gotta hit the course all
right
let's do it
okay
[Music]
dude i'm a one-woman wrecking crew
boom
future's female
get it twisted bro will we bring celebs
on stream coco i think we have a guest
next week i believe so
[Music]
foreign
where am i
what is happening here
i'm just orb kicking you that's what i
did this weekend can i kick it you just
kicked some orcs yeah yeah yeah really
yeah
you went around town really just been
kicking over all the time
that's awesome
how many orbs did you see
5-0 or 1-5
by orbs you mean um
people
children they look like you mean
children they look like orbs you meet
children
oh dude stasis field time
stasis field grabbing objects aim at the
enemy then press ooh i love this
oh he played his mario maker game levels
look at this
dude this is great i got the force
basically
like kylo ren up at the schnizz
beth you know when we will hold another
string we will hold another stream next
monday
12 p.m pacific time
wow
also the amy is forgiving which i enjoy
in this
this game is super weird sean but it's
great
[Music]
joe pick uh zero is the answer to that i
got the power
i got the skills to pay the bills what
what i got the skills to pay the bills
what what i got the skills
yeah that's not messiah though is it
i got those girls they'll pay you the
bills
nevi oh yeah you call them scarabs
am i like in a different dimension or
something
yeah messiah hope is dead i'm hoping
he's dead
i got i juiced yo
i got the skill to pay the bills what
blocking the skills to pay the bills
i want to get this what is this this gem
down here
oh yeah oh my god x you fly so much
faster
ooh gravity kick
we're going here
they're bad guys down there oh there we
go
oh
your face bro
what now
boom
love this gravity kick situation
yeah
4 30 our time
takes about an hour ends at 5 30. yep we
try to tape our show it's called live to
take because we try to tape it as close
to
the actual time as possible so our
editors have less work to do
yeah they work hard enough it has to be
ready by 8 o'clock that's right to be
honest
on tvs
right
boom i'm just wasting these
i'll take those
this is great now i got the hang of this
whole system it's much easier
don't believe me
you can find most clips on team
google.com
or facebook
or facebook
for all these guys just like
are they gone
she still moves like an idiot let's see
dab
beth when will you ever play a lot of
dab requests i would play if we play uh
you play inside you should play inside
inside that's great oh that's like the
floppy guys
where are we at
better
i think i need to recharge my [ __ ] for a
second how do i do that
let me get on this side of things
nope not following my death quite yet
thank you
about to though
[Music]
let's separate charge
and have i done cosplay uh i've dressed
up for halloween as somebody who had
dressed up guile i think one year
um no i never have
i think it's like who what like
i would have to put so much on to look
like someone else like is there like a
white haired
character guy fieri in a game guy fury i
could cosplay this guy fury
um
you know i feel like i don't look it's
hard for me to dress up like someone
else because i already have such a
specific look
oh this guy's getting it
wow
[Music]
what now dudes
boom
bring it bring the noise bring the funk
that's what i say
shout out for the sport squash please
all right squash is great is squash the
one where you hit it against the wall
with squash
that's racquetball what's what's squash
ooh walter white people are saying
i could do walter white with the uh the
goat
did anybody see why him
and wasn't any good
oh yeah actually you know what somebody
made on my instagram
somebody awesome made uh
a photo
of conan and i hold on you gotta yeah
look it up it's great is it on your
instagram it's on my instagram yeah
uh it's a great clue piece of clueless
gamer artwork
it was really impressive they like made
conan super mario and me as girl
going keep going
it's close it's close
oh man maybe it's before
there it is
oh god this guy this place is lousy
these are like basically like space rats
[Music]
oh jeez
why am i gonna save this guy he's a dick
to me
uh
[Music]
this guy's a total jerk why should i go
save him
nope
cosplay's bob barker that's pretty good
paul parker
go is a cantus what's a cantus
[Music]
dusty we gotta kill these squids
oh jeez i'm gonna die here in a second
[Music]
where do i go
this is not going to be good
i need to be on the other side of
something ah yes woo
lucky
all right i'm looking for you boy
did we even bring the new clock
no we didn't bring the clock no
we got a new clock for the room
it's a very nice vlog
so he can just
i want him to just be grateful one time
that's all i want from this dude you
know i asked for so little
i'm gonna save him and he's gonna be
like thanks
i need to get up there
here we go
watch i'm gonna save him and then he's
gonna thank me oh there's a weird other
dude
oh look at you prick
all right let's go let's go
oh what is that thing
i'm supposed to hit it in the butt i
think
how do i hit that thing in the butt
there we go
boom killed it
don't worry about it i'll just kill
everything
kill them all great metallica
i think about robert durst
that's good to you
a little darker
[Music]
i got them all bro
wait where's the big one is there a big
one
oh jesus what the f
time to take to the skies
pow right in the kisser pow right in the
kisser
what
what
how do i kill this thing
[Music]
it's like inside of a rock
let's get some distance on it
uh
oh i
see
let's crack that shell
oh yeah right now boom
bam
say your thank you say thank you say
thank you
say thank you oh he's going to be
crushed
what
oh
boy
that thing looks weird
jesus
where's it at
gonna use my kick
dude this kick thing is great
what else you got what else you got
oh
that doesn't seem very cool
uh
oh i gotta hit its back
oh i can hit that thing
yikes
come on try to hit me dude what's up
okay well mission accomplished there
well done
all right i'm gonna go over here real
quick
grab this life gem you know
what ducks yeah where are the ducks at
people screaming
i missed the ducks i missed those ducks
remember the ducks what a great time we
had with the ducks
who did i hit it
i need to get it in that glowing thing
[Music]
there we go popped it
i'm basically just popping giant space
pimples in this guy right
now i gotta land on him
oh yeah i hit the last one old school
you're dead right
wait aren't you dead
dab for the ducks dab for the ducks
duck dab give it up
boom smashy smashers
this game is crazy where's the guy even
say thank you dude say thank you say
thank you
i popped all of his weird
space blisters
[Music]
you're welcome for saving your best
miner you just don't worry about it
is he going to apologize i can't wait
oh yes oh [ __ ] we got him
wow okay
no you should say like yeah damn damn
right it's good for you to say that
don't be nice
okay you know she's pumping him up she's
taking the moral high ground which i
think is very nice
[Music]
these two are going to end up getting
together i know it i'd love this cat by
the way i could watch this cat all day
jeez
all right well we're back to
miss happy fun times miss happy
cheese oh pete's all right guys well i
think that's going to do it we got
messiah to apologize yeah which i think
is amazing the goal of the game whatever
happens in this game whatever's left
it's not going to be as
good percent of the game but we got that
guy who apologized yeah it's really we
beat the we like we're only five percent
in this game but we're he was the real
boss
[Laughter]
we're emotionally 100 complete in this
game uh dab for the cat gotta do it guys
thank you for joining us with stream
coco we'll see you back uh the game was
gravity rushed to you it's really fun
it's great once you get past all the
chit chat in the first two percent of
the game it's super fun uh and we'll see
you guys next week uh monday at noon
right here for stream coco see you guys
later have a great week
[Music]
you